I'll never forget the time
thank you for
most magical moments
it was a splitsville bloodbath on the
beach during Tuesday night's bachelor in
paradise
as season six comes to a close
that's where in paradise as you know it
is over after host Chris Harrison
canceled the last cocktail party of the
season couples had to face the music
about whether or not they could make it
outside of paradise quite a few said
adios to the beach leaving Mexico solo
including Luke the poor man's Nick V but
not on purpose and quite possibly the
most Awkward rejection in the bachelor
franchise to date this has never
happened before
[Music]
so briefs are done the rose is there
anyone else who would like Luke's Rose
tonight
anyone
right then there was tisha and Jay PJ's
split that tore everyone up including
Taoiseach
[Music]
my attention
but she stuck to the split leaving
paradise alone more jamás about to come
out leading up to next week's finale
only four couples remain Dylan and
Hannah who dropped the l word there's a
real possibility I told my wife that I
looked it today Demi and Christian
paradise is amazing it was so fun so
emotional but ultimately all worth it
very very good so much fun flais and
Nicole and Chris and Katie will get
engaged and who will go home
brokenhearted
according it to the fire promo we'll get
those answers during next week's show
this is gonna be a successful season
there will be love found in Paradise I
will tell you how much or how far it
goes but there will be love and then
we'll get a reunion with B bombs we're
gonna have a serious problems you're a
[ __ ] doing that's why tears and John
Paul Jones getting down on one knee
do you see
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]